hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my agents of shield episode 7 video
one step closer to secret warriors I
think they're slowly wrapping up this
lash plotline I'm interested to see if
it pushes into the second half of the
season but just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet also
there's some really cool surprises that
I learned about last night that I'll
talk about at the end of the video but
starting with top 5 WTF Fitz and Simmons
are the new Glenn in Maggie
of agents of Walking Dead if you weren't
sure about that conversation at the end
that they had where she said I meant
every word that I said it was when he
was listening to her recording where she
was like I had this cabin that I dream
about where we could go and she kind of
trails off she's basically saying that
she's in love with Fitz if it's kind of
tries to brush over it oh you were
delirious you didn't have any water and
she's like no I meant everything I said
let's just watch the Sun Rise so they
are turning this ship into a literal
thing on the show I don't know what
that's gonna look like obviously they're
not gonna like beat you over the head or
bore a hole in your chest with it or
anything like that but if you are big
fans of Fitz and Simmons and the
universe is giving you this gift on my
number 4 WTF Lincoln versus lash not
quite as crazy as say like zoom versus
Barry on the flash season 2 or even May
in Mockingbird kicking the out of
Hydra agents but but I do feel like
we're gonna be seeing more of these
inhuman fights the problem is is that it
costs a lot of money to do CG effects on
screen so I think they try to find ways
around that so I think they're trying to
work the kinks out before the back half
of the season they do more secret
Warriors stuff now that they contain
lash and Lincoln is back with the shield
team I think we're like one step closer
to that secret warriors team
thankfully they shuttle Joey away before
lash could get him so he's still alive
so he that's like one more person they
could put on the team I know my number 3
WTF Andrew flashes back and we see how
lash was created it seems like it was
actually a booby trap
Joey had a synthetic crystal rigged to
go off and release the mist whenever the
book was opened now I don't know if this
is part of a prophecy or if it was just
an accident
but it seems like Andrew was always
destined to become lashed like it wasn't
a special crystal or some special spell
or magic or anything like that he would
have always turned into lash no matter
where he took in the Terrigen mists the
weird thing about it though is that he
talks about his instinct taking over and
him being the Cure putting all these
other people down was that always his
desk
is lash to coal the heard the way he
talks about instinct is really important
I think because lash mode is kind of
like when he hooks out like when banner
Hulk's out there's the Hulk mind like
the whole cast his own consciousness
that's part of banners mind so whatever
banner does when he is Hulk he's really
only acting on subconscious thoughts
that banner has like if he's annoyed by
something he's gonna smash it when he's
the Hulk because he won't have the
control to not smash it when he's banner
the way Andrew talked about lash it's a
little bit different it's almost like he
feels like he has no control when he's
lash but that might just be the writers
mixing words it might just be like the
Hulk like Andrew when he's acting as
andrew has these thoughts where he's
like we need to get rid of these
Inhumans that are causing problems we
need to put them down so when he's in
lash mode the last part of his brain
maybe just acts out on those thoughts
they were just a little unclear about
how much control Andrew had when he was
in lash mode like he sees me where he's
able to consciously depower himself I
think they were going for Avengers age
of Ultron here you know where Black
Widow brings the Hulk back down into
banner mode just calming him down but
they did say there's a ticking clock on
this lash but like eventually he's
either gonna be lash all the time or
it's gonna be Andrew all the time I
think we as fans would rather see them
free the beasts full-time just be like
okay Andrew you were fun we want lash
all the time now but out of my number
two WTF Ward has a grand plan for
revenge to kill Coulson that he's
seemingly getting swept up in with
powers Boothe here and Rosalind so I
feel like that end tag with Coulson like
cut you know coming out like right after
they had sex was meant to be this really
shocking horrific moment I really didn't
take it that way because I actually I
liked them together they have so much
chemistry but I was surprised that they
turned it into a literal thing like they
actually had sex sometimes it's more fun
when they don't and you see them share
those long stairs where you're like
there's definitely implied sex happening
somewhere in this gaze but the mid
strike that they've done in the past
with Rosalyn were they're like oh we're
not supposed to trust her she's with the
government she wants to take down shield
she wants to kill all these Inhumans or
at least box them up I'm wondering if
this is just a continuation of that like
maybe she doesn't know the powers Boothe
is Hydra I know a lot of people are
wondering because he was in Avengers as
part of the world security council if
he's playing the same character I think
that he is but we never had a name for
that character and you look at the I am
cb4 that there's no listing for his name
and Avengers so I think agents of shield
has a lot of Liberty with what they do
with this character but just a tie to
the Captain America movies again if you
remember during Winter Soldier when
Robert Redford's character was talking
to that big Security Council that was
the same council from the first Avengers
film they just had different actors
so if shield was destroyed during that
movie I'm wondering if that council has
changed or if it still exists that'll
probably get addressed during Captain
America Civil War because the government
itself becomes a big character in that
movie via Martin Freeman Martin Freeman
is kind of like the Coulson of the
governmental organization in Captain
America Civil War you can see how like
they would use him for a comedy in that
situation or it's like oh my god I got
to deal with all these superheroes but
on to my number one WTF may actually try
to kill Andrew as lash Coulson asked her
how did you know that that wasn't going
to kill him and she's like I I didn't
know she was trying to put him down
hardcore Old Yeller style lash has
rabies you have to kill him the real
question though here's my big question
for you guys do you think that lash can
be rehabilitated and work with this new
secret Warriors team that they're gonna
be developing on the show I feel like
the answer is no I feel like long term
blair Underwood the actor that plays
this guy will go off the show like we
won't see lash anymore it'll be like a
whole situation where he just flies off
in a quintet we don't see him again my
only real problem with this week's
episode is the may Andrew drama like
they're setting up a lot of big things
but I feel like it would have been more
interesting say if Jemma Simmons had
become lash and they had just teased
that out longer like they'd done this
Fitzsimmons thing where they come
together after she's been marooned on
this planet so she tries to get her
friend back but then it's someone who
used to hate Inhumans she's turned into
one herself so I feel like that would
have been a more interesting storyline
but I guess I've just never been a big
fan of Andrews character and in the
problem with the may romance storyline
is that they want to give her this
backstory but I feel like it's too
little too late like they waited too
long to develop this backstory for her
Fitz and Simmons are believable because
like from day one they established that
there is something between them that
goes a little bit beyond friendship the
problem with Mays character though is
that like in this grand narrative she's
kind of been replaced by roselyn's
character because you always have like
the person that gets paired with Coulson
that used to be
now it's Roslin so it's like what do you
do with me like what's her storyline
well why don't we give her this Beauty
and the Beast thing which is funny
because she was actually in the Disney
movie as Mulan I do feel like they've
been treading secret warriors water all
season but they wanted to do this lash
plot first so it's like we know what's
coming but they've been holding off for
like eight or nine episodes so it's like
why don't why don't you just do the
thing we all want to see I feel like
they should have started with secret
warriors like with a bunch of people
with powers at the beginning of the
season then have lash come in and start
picking them off like who's picking off
the members of the team here oh wow
it's Andrew that to me would have been a
little bit more interesting because it's
like when you watch a Marvel show where
they say they're doing secret warriors
and then you get like six episodes with
them not doing Secret Wars you're just
like I don't understand what's happening
again anytime they put the Marvel title
on the show there's there's certain
expectations that you have but the
really cool surprises is that there's
gonna be special Star Wars footage
coming tonight on ABC and then tomorrow
on Disney now it's gonna be like two
completely different things so I will do
videos for both I think it's gonna be a
new clip tonight tomorrow is gonna be
more of a behind-the-scenes kind of
thing so be sure to subscribe to get
everything and I am still doing like a
Star Wars tickets giveaway then I'll
just all tie-in with those videos why
guys wait for all that stuff to post you
can click here for all my Star Wars
trailer videos that I've been posting
and you can click here for last night's
episode of arrow they see something
really big at the end of the episode I
don't want to say here because it's
super spoilery but you should definitely
check it out I think they had something
big coming thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you